Hey I is probably the most important thing humanity is
that has ever worked on and I think of it
as something more profound than electricity or fire and anytime
you
work with technology you need to learn to harness the
benefits.
And while minimizing the downside.
You know stepping back when you think about you know
a lot of problems in the world today it's because
we typically have a constraint on resources AI for the
first time I think overtime offers a different construct.
Things which are constrained and look like a zero sum
game today may not be so in the future take
education for example it's really difficult to educate people in
a cost effective way of AI mean fundamentally changed that
equation.
It may make it possible for us to have clean
cheap renewable energy for the future.